wusstest du wie glücklich du deine
Pflanzen mit Honig und Zimt machen
kannst ich denke wir sind uns alle einig
dass man niemals genug Pflanzen haben
kann oder die einfachste Art Pflanzen zu
vermehren ist es einfach ein Stück
abzuschneiden und einzupflanzen das
ganze nennt sich stecklingsfamilieung
und was wir dabei machen ist im Grunde
nichts anderes als unsere Mutterpflanze
eins zu eins zu klonen what der Honig
und der Zimt sind dafür echte
Wundermittel dazu erzähle ich dir gleich
mehr aber vorher schnappt der erstmal
eine saubere und scharfe Gartenschere
dass die Schere scharf ist ist vor allem
deswegen wichtig damit die Pflanze an
der Stelle wo wir schneiden nicht so
gequetscht wird weil sie dann an der
Stelle viel schlechter Wurzeln bilden
kann und das wollen wir ja gleich
erreichen und sauber natürlich damit
unsere pflanzenbabys nicht von vorne
rein mit irgendwelchen chart-erregern
infiziert werden es gibt tausende
Pflanzen die du über Stecklinge
vermehren kannst und wenn du deinen
eigenen Pflanzen Nachwuchs siehst dann
musst du auch nicht mehr ständig neue
Pflanzen kaufen wenn man Stecklinge
machen will hat man zwei Möglichkeit
unten einmal kann man zum Beispiel den
Rosmarinzweig den wir jetzt hier haben
unten ein bisschen entblättern und dann
in ein Wasserglas stellen bis er Wurzeln
bildet man kann aber den Steckling jetzt
auch einfach direkt in die Erde stecken
solange die schön feucht bleibt als Erde
kannst du entweder Anzuchterde verwenden
oder Blumenerde eins zu eins mit Sand
mischen das funktioniert zum Stecklinge
ziehen auch richtig gut aber hier haben
wir eine Wunde und es passiert leider
nicht selten dass so Erreger in unseren
Stecklingen eindringen können oder ein
anderes Problem der pflanzennachwuchs
will einfach nicht anwachsen darum
kümmern wir uns auf jeden Fall gleich
noch aber jetzt machen wir uns erstmal
auf den Weg zum nächstgelegenen
weidebaum weil wir da nämlich ein
magischen Cocktail ansetzen
[Musik]
für die Bewurzelung sind wer hätte das
gedacht die bewurzelungshormone
zuständig und deine Pflanzen wachsen
viel besser an wenn wir hier ein
bisschen nachhelfen ist euch schon mal
aufgefallen dass Weiden super schnell
Wurzeln schlagen im Frühling könnte man
Weidenzweige sogar verkehrt herum
einpflanzen und sie würden trotzdem
anwachsen das liegt daran dass Weiden
von Natur aus eine ganze Menge von
diesem Hormoncocktail bilden und ich
glaube dass unsere Teenager zu Hause
ganz happy sind wenn sie meinen
Schlückchen von diesem Cocktail
schlürfen dürfen um diesen
bewurzelungscocktail herzustellen
brauchst du ungefähr zehn junge
Weidenzweige jetzt einfach die jungen
beiden Zweige kleinschneiden und dann
zwei bis drei Tage lang in Wasser ziehen
lassen
zwei Tage sind vergangen jetzt gieße ich
das weidenwasser durch so einen Sieb und
die ganzen Zweige und Blätter
rauszufiltern und dann kann man das auch
ein paar Wochen aufbewahren und immer
wieder zum bewurzeln im Garten verwenden
aber bei beiden Methoden haben wir immer
noch das Problem dass Erreger in unsere
Pflanze eindringen können und da kommt
der Honig und der Zimt ins Spiel der
honig wirkt nämlich antiseptisch und
verschließt unsere Schnittwunde und der
Zimt wird gegen Pilzerreger und ist
antibakteriell und deswegen nehmen wir
jetzt unseren Steckling und bevor wir
irgendwas anderes machen tauchen wir den
in Honig und dann ins Zimt und dann
können wir das ganze entweder in Wasser
stellen oder in die Erde pflanzen aber
statt normalem Wasser könnt ihr da
besser das weidenwasser nehmen dass wir
gerade hergestellt haben weil die
Pflanze dann viel schneller wurzelt und
wenn ihr euch dazu entscheidet dass ihr
die Stecklinge einfach nur in die Erde
steckt dann nehmt ihr einfach das Weiden
Wasser als Gießwasser
ich möchte euch noch einen Trick zeigen
der vor allem bei Beerensträuchern
richtig toll funktioniert das hier ist
die Johannisbeerstrauch und wir brauchen
jetzt einen möglichst schweren Stein
denn flache Unterseite hat wir sind ja
heute in der Mission unterwegs Pflanzen
zu klonen und wir wollen ein neues
Johannes Baby aus diesem unteren Ast
machen und deswegen machen wir jetzt
unter dem Ast erstmal ein Stückchen Erde
frei so dass da wirklich nackter
Erdboden rausguckt
ich gehe kurz meine Schere sauber machen
wir haben ja gerade gelernt das ist ganz
wichtig ist dass die immer sauber ist
jetzt ritzte ich hier mit meiner Schere
an der Unterseite dieses Astes und ganz
bisschen die Rinde ein einfach nur um
die ein kleines bisschen zu verletzen
nicht die Rinde komplett abschellen bei
der Ast dann hier viel schneller Wurzeln
bilden wird aber wir haben ja gelernt
wenn man da Pflanze schon Wunden zufügen
muss denn die am besten auch gleich
behandeln deswegen kommt da jetzt Honig
und Zimt drauf dann drücken wir unseren
Ast mit der Verwundeten stelle hier auf
das Stück Boden das wir geöffnet haben
sitzen da einfach den Stein drauf damit
der Ast an der Stelle richtig schön am
Boden fixiert ist hier schaut der Rest
von der Pflanze raus und so ungefähr in
zwei drei Monaten können wir dann
hingehen und die Pflanze hier
durchschneiden weil sich unten schon so
viele Wurzeln gebildet haben dass wir
hier eine komplett neue
johannisbeerpflanze haben ich gieße das
ganze jetzt noch mit meinem Weiden
Wasser an für die extra
bewurzelungspower und ihr könnt euch da
drüben ein Video zum Thema Basilikum
vermehren und Basilikum ernten und so
weiter anschauen da gibt es richtig
coole Tricks wie man aus einem
Supermarkt Basilikum endlos viele
Pflanzen rausholen kann ansonsten geht
raus und macht die Welt ein bisschen
grüner und wir sehen uns im nächsten
Video wieder bis dann macht's gut
tschüss
Süßigkeiten und Cocktails ich bin echt
ein Rabenmutter